we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p today's
voicemail is depressing i did a segment
earlier this week explaining that there
are lots of topics that i've been self
censoring on because the audience
reaction just makes it not worth it one
of those is i mentioned any time I talk
about Tulsi Gabbard people just attack
me for being a shill for smearing her
whatever and that this doesn't happen
with other Democratic candidates so that
I shy away from critiques of Tulsi
Gabbard someone heard me explain this
and they sent me a voicemail saying they
don't like my criticism of Tulsi Gabbard
from that video I didn't criticize her
this is proof in the pudding of exactly
what I'm talking about take a listen to
this hello this is Michael from
Worcester
come on tibet i saw your video on this
are you censoring yourself on the far
left i I didn't like your attack a Tulsi
Gabbard I think she has some very valid
ideas on foreign policy and she gets way
too much hate this is exactly what I'm
talking about
I did not criticize Tulsi Gabbard in
that video
what Krita tak are you talking about
what I said in the video was when I talk
about or critique Tulsi unlike with
other candidates who are polling one
percent
I am instantly attacked for smearing her
for being a shill if I critique any
other candidate the feedback I get is
about the substance you're proving
exactly what I pointed out I can't even
mention her name without people saying
stop attacking Tulsi you don't like my
attack on her I said nothing about her
other than saying when I mention her
people attack me and here you are doing
it uh it's almost like a parody I it
I'm almost at a loss for words because
this is exactly the thing I was saying
in the video is what's going on and
someone reacts by saying I don't like
that attack on Tulsi there was no attack
there was no attack we're in serious
trouble folks
based on this level of uh it seems like
some kind of compromise comprehension or
some kind of cult of personality that's
creating a blind loyalty were mentioning
someone without glowing apparently is
now considered an attack I don't know
but this is extraordinarily depressing
I'm not even gonna tell you what's on
the bonus show it's it's a good bonus
show I'm very rattled by that voicemail
become a member the bonus show is a good
one today